i am nick gillespie with reasontv we
want to welcome the Barack Obama
administration in Washington DC we
didn't agree much with Obama on the
campaign trail but we are all looking
forward to a hell of a lot of change
here in DC and some of us even have a
little bit of Hope left at us we've
asked some of the reasons staff to talk
about their big fears and hopes for an
Obama presidency my biggest hope for the
Obama administration is it will see both
a reduction in executive power which is
what Obama is promised as well as a move
in the right direction on the drug war
which means at least a small amount of
decriminalization my biggest hope of an
Obama administration is that he sets the
right tone for America given the
importance of investor confidence and
consumer confidence in the recovery of
our economy my hope is that he focuses
on efficient government my biggest hope
for the Obama administration is a return
to cynicism I expected the American
people after this early period of
enthusiasm about the Obama
administration will go back to eating
Twinkies and watching TV and generally
being cynical and apathetic about
politics and my biggest hope for an
Obama administration is that he's going
to reconnect with this more humble
foreign policy that we saw earlier in
the campaign where the u.s. does not
solve each and every one of the world's
problems with military force my biggest
hope for the incoming Obama
administration is that there will be an
easing up of the drug war which has been
a tragic failure of American policy for
70 years and I am encouraged by the
ending of Don't Ask Don't Tell or the
promised adding a benefit to help my
biggest hope is that the Obama
administration will maintain a woman's
right to abortion is being safe and
legal in the United States that science
and scientific information will be fed
into the policy process and an accurate
and fair way and that the gay rights
agenda will be expanded my big hope for
the Obama presidency is that he'll
really close out over 400 years of
incredibly odious racial discourse in
America that shifted the focus of our
attention from individual efforts and
individual talents to group and
collective identities that's always a
bad idea we've had far more than enough
than we ever need to have again my
biggest fear is that the selection of
Eric Holder's attorney general signifies
a disrespect for the second
holder after all his favorite expansive
and restrictive gun control throughout
his entire career my biggest fear is
that in the process he will
over-regulate reaching too far trying to
take what may have worked at the local
level but doesn't necessarily translate
to the national level becoming too
enamored with his own legend thinking
that anything is possible focusing too
much on short-term gains and not the
long-term consequences of those actions
my biggest fear for the Obama
administration ironically enough is the
expansion of executive power people love
Obama right now and I fear that they'll
be willing to give Obama all kinds of
powers they never would have given to
George Bush my biggest fear of an Obama
administration is that his retrograde
economic policies are going to take us
back to the dark old days of the
stagflation airy 1970s my biggest fear
is a massive massive expansion of
government spending and government
interventions but in the economy in a
sort of grand new new deal type way
biggest fear is that the Obama
administration will nationalize health
care and making sure that we get equally
bad health care for everybody forever
and that will stop medical innovation
completely in its tracks my big fear of
the Obama administration is that he is
going to pick up exactly where George W
Bush left off and massively expand the
size and scope of the government when
we're talking about spending when we're
talking about foreign policy and
adventurism overseas or we're talking
about regulation on businesses as well
as everyday life
you